after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future the game is set in are the last
group of space explorers to meet them
you'll head to the capital city of new
atlantis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to constellation we have a lot
to talk about
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all
what's
out
there these artifacts could be
everything we've been looking for
as to what they are
what they're building
[Music]
you'll be part of solving that puzzle
now
so you found something the new guy found
it
you dug up the artifact right that means
you saw it the visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many scattered across the galaxy
if we can find more we can unlock their
secrets beautiful isn't it the man who
sold me this told me that it spoke to
him of course the settle systems is full
of groups with other priorities
that's the crimson fleet everybody get
ready
fleet doesn't follow the rules agreed to
work for uc system together we take down
these cutthroat pirates
we're not just here to shoot the bad
guys we're peacekeepers we protect the
people of the freestar collective
when you sign up with a crimson fleet
no one quits
the only way help
is death
the path ahead may be dangerous
but we are not stopping
most dusties don't even make it this far
because whatever lies at the end of this
road
will change humanity
forever